the jogan experience I mean the first
time I heard of a sex robot was probably
maybe 10 years ago and it was this video
and a bunch of people and I was in
graduate school sent me this video
because I knew what I I was studying sex
and it was I don't know if you either of
you Jamie has seen this video but it
went viral and it was this early version
of a sex robot but it was like the
silicone face silicone face with a wig
and she I'll say she was eating a banana
but she wasn't actually eating a banana
and it was basically like this head
attached to a stick and had a sheet over
it and so you couldn't see the rest of
the the robot you just saw the the face
of it but then the the manufacturer
shows you it's just like a a broomstick
so what I thought was interesting is
that even though it looks so hilariously
bad that there was obviously a market
for it because so many people were
interested in looking at this video and
also that people were buying this
product but now you fast forward I think
it was like 5 years ago there's a huge
um I would say
not moral panic but people there's a lot
more discussion about it they said the
robots are coming I don't think the
technology is quite there yet I wrote
about it quite a bit at the time and now
they're saying probably another year or
two is going to be really coming in in
terms of the popularity that these
robots are going to be incorporated into
everyday life in some cases because when
I think of social media the internet AI
like you said is becoming so mainstream
and so ubiquitous what's going to happen
when we have these robots that are now
being integrated into human life and
what happens when the technology does
get so good that you know they are more
humanlike and they are able to meet
people's emotional needs and maybe even
physical needs what's going to happen to
us then yeah we're going to stop
breeding I mean maybe that's the the
ai's plan it's to not exterminate the
human race but to give them options so
they just completely stop reproducing
make the options far more attractive and
in a in a way we've kind of done that
like with video games um like how and
video games and just being online I mean
I'm sure you've seen the statistics of
how many people are single today and how
many men have gone like more than a year
without any sex yeah I the stats here
it's like 30% of male Millennials and
20% of women it's wild yeah that's a lot
it's crazy and what what what is taking
the place of them going out and trying
to find uh a mate what is it well it's
the internet it's video games it's being
constantly stimulated by this artificial
realm that you exist in when you're
playing Call of Duty and it's uh you
know interacting with people only online
and not having to go out to have your
just some sort of intellectual or some
sort of social discourse connection yeah
fulfilled in your life but it's only
through this weird surface way do you
think that AI video games that um not
avoidance of in-person connection but
that that fulfillment of connection
through online means do you think that's
going to become a replacement for real
life interaction eventually it will for
a lot of people yeah I think there's
going to be people that reject it
there's going to be people that enjoy
going outside and it's going to be you
know it is now it's a thing where you
know people post their social media
they're out hiking you know and they're
giving people advice like hey you know
put your phone down go experience the
real world but you know in a lot of
cases it's falling on deaf ears because
it's not as fulfilling for people that
are you know very um uncomfortable with
social situations now and I think people
young people in particular are more and
more uncomfortable than ever before in
those type of situations because they
don't have any experience in them
anymore and they're just most of the
time they're not interacting with people
my my real fear my genuine fear and I
don't even know if it's a fear here my
[Music]
um my
my my concern let me say that is that
we're we're going to go extinct like
that we're going to be replaced by an
artificial life form and I think that is
probably what we do I think it probably
exists elsewhere in the universe as well
that we find out that the the confines
of
biological beings and the limitations of
their ability to evolve physically
they're so slow to adapt you know to go
from a single celled organism to a
professor at Harvard is a long [__]
sludge through evolutionary history it
took a long time to get to this point
but to go from an Atari uh pong computer
to artificial general intelligence is
only a few decades it's very quick and
when that does happen and when you see
these robots but now these robots are
not this generation but five generations
later or maybe AI figures out all the
problems with these robots and makes
exmachina when you get like that who's
the woman the really hot lady Alia
viander yeah will you get one of those
that was an amazing movie amazing movie
scary so scary and I think that's coming
I mean I think when that movie came out
that was like sort of like abstract like
oh yeah that's not really going to
happen but now that's what I used to
think I thought no this is like people
are it's overblown but I don't know now
I don't know now either I think it's
happening I think it's going to happen
and I think that's what the human race
does and I think that's why we have this
insatiable thirst for technological
innovation that it's like literally
hardwired into us to build something
better so I mean I would love to talk to
more people who are in the industry
working on this stuff because I know
many people they're doing it secretly
and hiding CU they're is so much stigma
around doing anything with an
application to sex or sexuality so
people I've talked to who work in
technology they will usually have one
business that is you know doing really
well that's forward- facing and then
they'll usually use that same technology
in the sexuality capacity but that side
of things they don't really advertise
and you know they don't really talk too
much about it unless it's with someone
like me they know they trust me and they
know that you know I'll talk to people
off the Record even if they prefer that
confidentiality but I'm just curious to
understand you know what is it like
working that industry and what direction
is the technology going in because I
consider myself to be pretty open-minded
and I just I just want to understand
what's actually happening and what's
what's going to be the result of that
because you see people who were really
upset a couple years ago saying like the
robots are going to increase sexual
violence they're going to make people
objectify women and I do think that for
people who already have those views
about
women you know maybe they might be a
little bit more not so nice but I don't
think the average person is going to be
turned into this horrible monster
because of this technology but you know
now it's becoming so mainstream I don't
know you know I'm always open to
changing my mind as well so I'm curious
to to hear what people think about it
well don't you think that just like
social media kind of stunts people's
ability to communicate in real life that
sex robots will stunt people's ability
to have a real meaningful romantic
relationship with someone I think if
you've never been with someone or if you
are particularly self fish probably cuz
I I previously thought most people will
prefer a real life person to a robot and
I also thought the technology is so far
off that like the early prototypes of
these robots were not really that um
convincing we'll say so I didn't think
that we'd get to a point where it would
be comparable but we are we are getting
there what is the state-of-the-art of
sex robots in December of
2023 what can we see something what does
it look like I mean they look re like
pretty good physically they look I mean
they're obviously not made of human
flesh but they look pretty similar to a
human being and you can customize it you
can change various parts pretty much any
part of the body you can make it exactly
what you want which I understand why
some people find that offensive because
they're saying a woman is not just an
amalgamation of parts that you pick and
choose as to your liking I totally get
that yeah but it's not a really really a
woman I mean that's like saying you know
oh a car is not an amalgamation of Parts
you shouldn't be able to pick the wheels
like what but I [__] car like that's
not a real woman that's a robot like at
what point unless it gets to a person
you know or if someone's comparing their
partner to a robot or a doll like that's
not okay that's that's gross Behavior
well it's also what's going on with
young kids they're comparing themselves
to people that are using filters and
thinning their waist and widening their
hips and doing all these things with
apps that are not representative of most
biological human beings and you know
that's what and hate talked about that
it's causing all this self harm and
disdain it's like it's it's a weird
place we're in that's never been really
traversed before with human society as
far as we know has never gone through
anything like this before I was reading
a statistic yesterday that one in 10
adolescents has considered suicide which
is that that's terrifying that's really
really sad wow what did it used to be
I'm not sure I'll find out so what is
like what's the company what is one
company that has the state-of-the-art
sex robot so we could look it up can I
reveal it to you at a later date cuz I I
want see it I know you do but there's
one company that I was talking to qu
like I knew quite well but they've since
gone under because of the stigma they
were being harassed the family was being
harassed so they said we're we're not
making these anymore oh well they're not
around anymore so let's talk about them
what if I show you one without we just
don't say the name I just put this up
online and you can tell if this if
there's better or worse than okay I
think that's silly but let's go okay
yeah this wait this is a robot
e Jesus
yep they have some sort of AI in it it
says that feel connected with
sense X mobile app oh this so this is a
real doll so they used to have those
real dolls and they used to just be
silicone right they were just like still
it's still the same thing it's still the
same thing but now it talks yeah and how
much does it do uh I don't let's see a
video
Go full
[Music]
screen I'm not showing this on the air
no okay good no cuz it's yeah I get it's
a little
graphic so we're looking at body parts I
am NOA I am Harmony I am Solana we are
part of you think it's weird they give
them stri names driven robotic
dolls and they're here to become your
perfect companion wo our time together
will be magical you have never met
anyone like us before we have remarkable
unprecedented features like a modular
head system that allows us to create a
multitude of Expressions we blink we
move we speak and we do it all just for
you our faces can easily be swap to
accommodate your
desires my lifp syn mechanisms allow me
to interact with you ver our bodies are
skillfully and carefully crafted down to
the most delicate details what if I told
you that I could feel you that's right
with sensory of grades I consent I will
be able to react to your every
touch it's so funny cuz as a former sex
researcher this doesn't have any effect
on me at all one that has never before
been
possible but are they moving this is the
thing those were all just stationary
yeah currently they're stationary but so
they're stationary and they just talk it
says there's some sort of articulation
but I mean up walk articulation
articulate but but I think they will be
able to move on their own in the coming
years right because this used to be just
a doll and now it moves around a little
the neck moves articulating neck real
doll can turn left right up and down the
body the real skillfully cled finest
details although it's not equipped with
animatronic Parts yet it can be
positioned in MO moved in hundreds of
positions so the bodies can't move yet
but the heads can move but that's just a
matter of time right didn't used to be
the bodies or the heads didn't used to
move they used to just be like and now
you know used to be a blowup doll yeah
like that company is on has been doing
quite a bit it's pretty cool weird I
mean you guys should get one for the
studio yeah
no not for use I meant just to like hang
well even hanging around it would be
[__] creepy it's gone one day we're
just going to wonder who took it yeah
yeah what if it smells weird like
someone do something to this um how much
they cost a couple thousand dollar I
think depends on how how advanced you
want it to be grand eight grand up to up
to 600 to 8 Grand I'm seeing different
$600 to8 Grand yeah yeah oh what's the
upgrade what he what do he get more
articulation more voices and I don't
know you can get cheaper models but
they're not as high quality okay so
that's the state-ofthe-art
essentially yeah well 600 isn't even a
full thing it's just like a full just
the head no it's just the f a flashlight
version oh okay whole so at one point in
time we're probably going to be looking
at someone that looks like that lady
from exmachina that is a a sex robot and
probably knows how to manipulate you and
play games with you and excite you and
taunt you
and
woo yeah it's going to be
great